[Music]
all right
is inevitable one Must Destroy
in order to create
we are no Jedi
[Music]
I started hearing whispers
of thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
what happens when we find thrawn
such as you've never dreamed
[Music]
[Applause]
I've spent most of my life fighting a
war
that's why I'm trying to convince you to
help me prevent another one
you and I both know who could help you
with this
still just as stubborn as ever
I bet your master found you difficult at
times Anakin never got to finish my
training I walked away from him just
like I walked away from Sabine you never
made things easy for me
master
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can
but I'm counting on you to see this
through
nice haircut
sometimes we have to do what's right
regardless of our personal feelings
if we don't stop thrawn everything will
be in vain
[Music]
Anakin spoke highly of you
I'm not here to discuss my past we have
a lot of work to do once a rebel always
a rebel
thank you
[Music]
something's coming
something dark
that's it
foreign
[Music]
for some
War
for others
[Music]
it's been a while
things have changed
[Music]
started hearing whispers
about thrawn's return
heir to the Empire
[Music]
we have to prepare for the worst
the Jedi fell a long time ago
there aren't many left
[Music]
Perhaps it is time to begin again
there's like a major campaign that's
going on online to try to get me in Star
Wars
you on Twitter they don't follow buddy
no I think there's a good song internet
help me out
now might be a good time to welcome
Ahsoka herself I think
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God she looks amazing
there's a character that Dave filoni
created and worked with George Lucas on
in the Clone Wars we're telling the
story of this character has been trained
by the greatest Jedi of all times in
Anakin Skywalker
Ahsoka has been a really beloved
character for many many years there's a
lot of Ahsoka love today
with Ahsoka it's time that she came in
to her in a way we've never seen it
before
is so compelling she is on fire and she
knows her stuff she's in it
to see the scope of this story I can't
wait for people to watch it
we have to maintain that sense of fun
adventure and Imagination
it's quite extraordinary actually bring
this to life
Perhaps it is time to begin again
[Music]